casa todos é um prazer enorme aqui um
espetáculo eventos e eu falar um pouco o
assunto um pouco diferente talvez seja
também a democratização mas dessa vez a
democratização do dinheiro
em 2008 o mundo testemunhou o início de
dois grandes experimentos monetários mas
em comum esses experimentos têm apenas a
data de início porque não poderiam ser
mais distintos um é coercitiva um e
outro é voluntário
nesses experimentos é liderado por esse
grupo de pessoas
esses são os banqueiros centrais mais
poderosos do planeta são os donos das
impressoras de dinheiro das moedas de
reserva como o dólar o euro e em óleo e
esses ferimentos que tem o apoio de
quase todos economistas da maior parte
dos economistas
só que o experimento um pouquinho
diferente porque os participantes desse
experimento não tem alternativa são
obrigados a participar como se fossem
cobaias mas não é desse experimento
quero falar até porque daqui nada de bom
vai sair o experimento não quero falar é
esse foi criado por um indivíduo um
completo anonimato e muito influenciado
pela cultura sai foi punk dos anos 90 e
foi um experimento que começou sem
nenhum financiamento sem nenhum apoio
formal de economista de centro acadêmico
de uma universidade nem o apoio de
qualquer um de edição e hoje é o projeto
de computação distribuída mais potente
do planeta inteiro longe do segundo
colocado mas antes de a gente se
aprofundar um pouco de contexto
todo mundo está cansado sabendo a
revolução das telecomunicações da
tecnologia desde a invenção do telégrafo
no século 19 que era internet da época
internet vitoriana depois que o telefone
com radio tv computador o computador
pessoal os telefones móveis e depois de
criar a internet o crescimento foi
simplesmente exponencial e assustador
hoje qualquer um de vocês com um simples
telefone móvel com um simples mas fone
conectado à internet vocês conseguem
criar um canal do youtube por exemplo e
fazer concorrência até à rede televisão
e isso basta um telefone móvel e uma
conexão internet você pode compartilhar
texto fotos tweets o que for
tudo a um custo quase desprezível
instantaneamente e disponível para o
globo hunter
mas se vocês tentarem remunerar alguém
ou serem remunerados tentarem pagar
alguém com a mesma facilidade que sim de
um meio aí você não conseguir aí não vai
ser possível porque isso porque esse
estado de coisas
um dos motivos é que é a indústria
financeira eo próprio sistema monetário
são incrivelmente fechados e anacrônicos
se alguém tentar enviar um tédio hoje
hoje em leão pede um dock para qualquer
pessoa vai pagar cerca de 10 reais e 10
reais para enviar um simples pede se
você tentar enviar dinheiro para fora do
país
aí vai ser mais caro ainda cerca de 50
dólares vai levar dias e isso se não
houver nenhum erro na mensagem que basta
um espaço a mais um espaço - o nosso
dinheiro fica no limbo durante semanas
quem não sabe aonde o dinheiro vai parar
nunca teve essa experiência sabe que é
das coisas mais desagradáveis pode
passar com alguém tentando fazer um
pagamento internacional porque isso
porque é tão complicado usar o dinheiro
na era digital
se o dinheiro nada mais é do que é nosso
jogo no banco nada mais é do que meros
dígitos eletrônicos
por que é tão difícil já um livro
eletrônico de um lado pro outro porque
precisa levar dias
é como se a indústria financeira não
tivesse sofrido de todos os avanços
tecnológicos que hoje nós temos porque é
verdade nosso sistema financeiro e
bancário eliete quadro para o mundo
moderno
um dos motivos é que ao contrário dos
arquivos digitais que podem ser
reproduzidos infinitamente o dinheiro de
não pode ser reproduzido porque se isso
acontecer ele vai ser relacionado e vai
perder poder de compra rapidamente
então a gente precisa ter certeza que
quando a gente transfere quando nosso
digital eletrônico sai da conta
tenho certeza que ele realmente sai da
conta vai parar na conta de quem estava
no nacional
se isso acontecer a gente poderia gastar
mais uma vez a mesma moeda o mesmo
dinheiro digital
e para lidar com essa questão chamada de
gasto duplo os bancos gasto muito
dinheiro com infra estrutura bancária
com segurança para manter um sistema sem
fraudes e com muita segurança para os
participantes
um outro motivo é que a gente vive hoje
em dia na chamada era das moedas
estatais
hoje é o nosso dinheiro o dinheiro
estatal cujo dono é o próprio governo e
por causa disso a gente tem uma criação
artificial uma barreira artificial
criada pelo homem chamado a fronteira
para quem não sabe essa aqui é a
fronteira do brasil com o uruguai no
número do sul país que é da cidade de
santana do livramento ea direita é a
cidade de rivera se imaginar um
brasileiro no uruguai tentando
transacionar aqui no meio da rua
ganhamos com um papel em espécie a rigor
seria uma atração internacional uma cela
aprovação de duas partes vão ser
intermediário não há problema
agora se eles tentarem fazer essa
transação usando o sistema bancário
brasileiro gama vai ter que mandar na
hora do pagamento do seu banco o banco
ela mora no pagamento do banco
correspondente que vai converter os
reais em dólares para mandar embora os
pagamentos do banco correspondente do
outro lado da fronteira e vai converter
os dólares em pesos que vai mandar um
pagamento para bancos sujeitos a mandar
o dinheiro se lê não tem sentido isso
não faz o menor sentido
imaginem vocês quando possa enviar um e
mail aparece na tela do telefone
a pergunta o crs meio pro brasil também
custa tanto reais ao email vai para a
china ainda que está a 50 reais e vai
demorar alguns dias
ana mas hoje é sábado 26 não funciona
não sabe no domingo
[Música]
não dá pra imaginar isso é realmente
interessado mas o quinto ensaio
o resto é o paradigma vigente para a
moeda por dinheiro para o sistema
financeiro que a gente vive mas está
mudando está mudando rapidamente graças
a uma tecnologia chamada beach boy bicho
é invenção tecnológica mais fascinante
eu diria que é mais importante desde a
versão desde a invenção da internet foi
uma moeda digital mas é muito mais do
que apenas uma moeda digital porque é
também um sistema de pagamentos global
sem fronteiras não depende de nenhum
banco central de nenhum governo de
nenhum banco e funciona uma rede
totalmente descentralizada
isso realmente nunca a gente nunca fez
algo parecido algo de fato
revolucionário e uma idéia um tanto
subversiva que o dinheiro paralelo um
dinheiro que não depende do governo
a gente entender melhor como funciona de
fato o sistema antes deve recorrer a
descrição dada pelo próprio criador do
mit foi que é e piu-piu electronic cash
exista um sistema de dinheiro eletrônico
pelo espírito piano mas a palavra chave
nessa descrição é a palavra cash que a
gente não tem uma tradução exata ou
literário português significa o nosso
dinheiro espécie de papel moeda
como é que funciona hoje em dia a gente
quiser fazer um pagamento com a moeda
basta a gente ia encontrar a pessoa que
a gente quer relacionar com os fãs do
pagamento entre duas partes não precisa
de nenhum intermediário e pagamento é
regressivo depois a gente paga uma
pessoa passou embora com o dinheiro dela
está boa não tem a quem recorrer e
tentar reverter aquele pagamento também
não precisa se conhecer as partes da
zona euro não precisa conhecer a gente
sabe a identidade rg cpf do jornaleiro
quando a gente vai na banca de jornal
comprar uma revista e meio você sabe nós
não precisa saber a identidade mas se a
gente fizer com os equipamentos e
enviamos somas maiores ou mais longas
distâncias
a gente não tem como escapar de um
sistema de pagamentos o que mais conhece
hoje em dia são os próprios bancos
existem sistemas de pagamento como o
paypal é um sistema de pagamento para o
ambiente online
mas o paradigma de hoje é moeda estatal
de um lado e sistemas de pagamentos de
outro a idéia como bystroy
paradoxalmente é replicar essas
propriedades do dinheiro físico do
dinheiro espécie pagamento sem
intermediários
não se precisa saber as identidades das
pessoas relacionamos e reversíveis a
replicar essas propriedades no ambiente
digital
só quando acontece algo extraordinário
ocorre porque a gente tem não apenas um
sistema de pagamentos não apenas uma
moeda mas os seus pagamentos também as
duas coisas ao mesmo tempo e isso é uma
das grandes inovações do beach boy toy
basta um telefone celular conectado à
internet em questões de segundos vocês
baixe o aplicativo uma espécie de
carteira digital e se conecta nessa
plataforma financeira internacional com
a possibilidade transacionar com
qualquer pessoa em qualquer lugar do
planeta transferindo qualquer soma de
dinheiro a um custo de dikulo sem
precisar comprovar renda compra dar um
comprovante de endereço e nada disso e
sempre reúne estudar conta ser
confiscado ao bloqueado qualquer pessoa
tentar impedir você estacionar ou então
inflacionar a sua moeda digital
corrompendo o poder de compra dela é
realmente revolucionária e subversiva
uma tecnologia como as que criou ela é
quem é que teve essa idéia tão louca e
fora da caixa
no auge da crise financeira em 2008 foi
no tubo um cara chamado satoshi nakamoto
publicou uma mensagem de uma mensagem
para uma lista de topografia online onde
ele dizia que estava criando um sistema
de dinheiro eletrônico pelo espírito e
nessa mensagem ele anexou um paper onde
nove páginas ele escrever como é que
sistema funcionaria
isso foi em outubro de 2008 três meses
depois ele disponibilizou um sistema
para quem quisesse começar a baixar e
construir a rede do b foi em janeiro
em 2009 o limite foi a primeira moeda
que se diz é de centralizada é a
primeira moeda digital descentralizada
porque se diz que a primeira
desatualizado porque outras tentativas
fazer uma moeda digital no passado
sempre acabavam tendo o mesmo problema
quando lhe davam a questão lugar do
outro que é o gasto do povo retomar
imagine que o gelo edital seja nada mais
do que um arquivo de computador que para
ele era uma pessoa bastante ex avançarem
anexar o arquivo na mensagem enviada a
gente sabe que quando a gente anexar um
arquivo no meio por exemplo o arquivo
original é apagado computador fizesse e
anexar esse mesmo arquivo ia pra outra
pessoa é plenamente possível se arquiva
o dinheiro digital a gente pudesse
gastar duas vezes esse dinheiro e ser um
problema para lidar com essa questão do
gasto duplo as outras tentativas de se
fazer uma moeda digital sempre
empregavam um terceiro de confiança na
entidade centralizada um ente
responsável pela validação das contas
para assegurar que não houvesse fraude e
também responsável pela emissão de moeda
digital
o vídeo foi obtido foi o primeiro a
conseguir resolver esse problema no
nosso duplo de forma descentralizada não
existe uma entidade central não me choca
não existe uma empresa responsável pelo
beach boy no início um dono desse
sistema é um protocolo de comunicação
assim como são os protocolos de
comunicação na internet tcp/ip não disse
um dono desse protocolo causam muita
perplexidade porque é é um modelo de
segurança que ele é o inverso do que a
gente conhece ea primeira pergunta que
vem à cabeça como não têm um bom
controlo quem controla não tem ninguém
fazendo a segurança não tem ninguém
responsável individualmente para essa
tarefa que é quando a segurança do
sistema que emite moeda
qual é o laço nessa moeda a grande
sacada do méxico foi conseguir delegar
essa tarefa que até hoje foi
centralizada para diversos usuários
voluntários que se asseguram todos os
dias
dedicando força computacional a rede
fazendo avaliação das ações e
assegurando que não haja nenhuma fraude
e nenhuma inflação de moeda e esse é
essa que é a quebra de paradigma porque
ao invés de tempo apenas uma entidade
unicamente contra um sistema onde
ninguém sabe o que está acontecendo com
ele o objetivo é inverter esse modelo de
segurança onde as transações são todas
completamente transparentes mas não se
sabe quem está relacionando e todos os
usuários estão constantemente
monitorando inspecionando e auditando
que ocorre no sistema é o novo modelo de
segurança eu sei que para muita gente
isso choca espanta que ela suspeita mas
é um sistema que já está funcionando há
quase oito anos e nunca teve nenhuma
fraude
jamais foi corrompido o livro contábil
do méxico é chamado bloquinho onde todas
as transações estão lá registradas um
sistema como esse com tantas
particularidades características
diferentes é e comércio fora da caixa em
algumas um tanto subversivas
ele tem diversas implicações por exemplo
a primeira delas é que sim e destroem é
é a primeira alternativa viável de uma
moeda privada isso não porque o estado
que isso vá conceder uma licença não
pode lamentar a criança chamada privada
pode concorrer com gente como ele bem
sabe o governo não gosta de concorrência
especialmente no âmbito monetário moeda
monopólio do estado mas admite que
existe não porque o governo ter mita que
existem sim porque é impossível para o
beach park
o objetivo é construir uma rede
totalmente descentralizado assim como a
rede do bit torrent que vocês já devem
ter conhecido ouvido falar até usado sem
saber tem uma rede para compartilhamento
de arquivos digitais utiliza a mesma
arquitetura de redes
isso quer dizer que é impossível para o
time que não tem quem será o ceará não
tem quem não existe um endereço físico
onde vocês possam mandar um oficial de
justiça com uma um mandado de segurança
19 em serra atividades acabou a
brincadeira
não dá mais não tem como fazer isso e
por conta disso foi também é uma uma
concorrência ao sistema bancário
a empresa de remessa internacional como
a western union ou então as entidades de
prover o serviço de mensagens em termos
internacionais entre bancos swift é uma
concorrência a todo esse sistema porque
a infração é cometida não precisa usar
esse sistema usa uma rede paralela ao
sistema financeiro tradicional
mas bacana isso tudo é que essa nova
tecnologia é muito mais do que apenas
dinheiro dinheiro é a primeira aplicação
a tecnologia ainda são tecnológica que é
uma vitória porque o futebol é verdade é
uma plataforma para inovação financeira
informacional aberta a todos e qualquer
um e sem necessidade de me pedir nenhuma
permissão e hoje em dia estão empresas
como a nasdaq que a bolsa de empresas de
tecnologia dos estados unidos que está
utilizando a tecnologia do beach boys
não porque ela esteja interessada na
moeda num dinheiro digital
mas sim que pode usar ela para registrar
outras informações digitais como por
exemplo fazer negociação de ativos de
ações e títulos de dívida registro de
titularidade de imóveis no governo de
honduras tem um projeto piloto para
fazer isso ou utilizar a rede do beach
boy para registro de documentos para
localização não haja uma espécie de
cartório digital porque outra das
inovações do vitória é que ele tem todas
as transações que ocorrem na rede ficam
registradas um grande arquivo digital
seu livro contábil do bitcoin chamado
the box tim e esse livro contábil que é
compartilhado ele é único e é mantido
por todos os usuários conectados na rede
e mantenha aquilo sempre atualizado com
novas sanções à medida que ela não
ocorrendo
e ele é um arquivo hoje em dia tão
robusto então computacionalmente um
praticável de forjar audi e de corromper
que quando antes era uma informação nele
é quase como se ela fosse imutável
algumas horas alguns dias é impossível
remover essa informação de lá isso tem
valor
isso tem muito valor no dia 17 de junho
deste ano na sexta feira às 7 da noite
mas eu e minha filha e como era a sexta
feira 7 à noite os cartórios estavam
fechados e eu como bom entusiasta da
tecnologia deixa de bom vou registrar
minha filha no box tim bishop o registro
ela nenhum sistema hla escrevente terça
feira à noite o nome dela alice coimbra
o ris 17 de junho de 2016
e essa informação está lá até hoje não
tem como ninguém a pagar ela está lá
para a posteridade
isso é apenas um exemplo do que pode ser
feito com essa tecnologia
e pra acabar quero deixar uma reflexão
com duas perguntas aqui pra vocês
obtive uma tecnologia e inclusiva
financeiramente inclusiva
então o que acontece quando a gente um
barca bilhões de pessoas desbancarizados
e um sistema financeiro realmente
internacional
a quantidade de pessoas no brasil apenas
no brasil que não têm acesso bancário é
estarrecedora
quase metade das pessoas no brasil não
têm acesso à conta bancária ou a
serviços financeiros básicos
qual é o potencial transformador é uma
tecnologia como essa que basta um
telefone móvel e acesso à internet e sem
concorrência ea inovação com 100 de fato
permitidas no âmbito da moeda e aqui não
tô falando de licença prévia para
renovar a autorização posterior está
realmente falando de inovação é
revolucionária disruptiva se realmente
tivesse um ambiente de inovação e de
liberdade para inovar no âmbito da moeda
será que a gente teria uma moeda melhor
uma moeda pior será quem seria uma moeda
mais ou menos inflacionárias seguem
seria talvez uma forma de moeda que a
gente consiga prever muito superior ao
que a gente tem hoje
será que é esse tipo de sistema que a
gente está precisando muito obrigado
pela atenção
[Aplausos]